barring money hopefully one second guys
we'll get to you in a second hey pictur
boy yeah I'm talking to you buddy look
at me I still have a quick little chat
come up on the ring come on
do you need help from Wardlow to get in
the ring bud it's one of our grips yeah
I didn't think so
you know when Cody decided to talk about
my crossroads I could have sworn I saw
you laughing last week isn't that the
case were you laughing well you know
what buddy all is forgiven all you have
to do is kiss the ring
[Applause]
humiliating
[Applause]
oh my god that's intimidation right
there oh look at no what are you the
double cross from mjf on one of a camera
dress no don't do that look pretty damn
good to me
what do you white trash Hicks think huh
[Applause]
are you guys done
Cody Rhodes
Cody Rhodes I'll be the first guy to
admit it you are without a shadow of a
doubt one of the greatest wrestlers of
this generation and with a microphone in
your hand bud
you are absolutely untouchable well with
the exception of one guy and of all the
people who open your mouth about you
decided to talk about that one guy well
to quote a legend bud you do not throw
rocks at a man with a machine gun and
when my mouth opens these bullets don't
miss
now Kony I heard your little business
proposal it was it was really cute don't
get me wrong I really enjoyed it but
Cody
I don't need your crap man and I damn
sure don't need your money because like
all of these swine unlike all of them I
got enough money to last me a lifetime
what I need from you Cody is for you to
suffer but there was one line you
decided to say Cody you decided to call
me a knockoff Chris Jericho are you guys
like that huh
you guys thought that was funny yeah
what
what an amazing dis Tony you must have
stayed up for hours on end sweating just
to think of that zinger I mean honestly
amazing is it is it cuz of my scarf code
man huh yeah
the same scarf that you and these morons
so boldly claim is fake
oh good let's talk about that word fake
it's very raposo t-that you use that
word fake because when I think of the
word fake I think of you I think of that
platinum blonde hair that looks like a
cat pissed on it I think of those Gary
Busey asked beaver Keith that I could
land a helicopter on and I think of all
the times you look at these fans and
claim you care about them well guess
what Cody I'll give you this there's one
thing about you that's very real and
that's your shitty little list
oh oh
sucker in succotash Cody I'm so sorry
did I offend you ha bud are you guys
upset
[Applause]
what did you do Tony you're gonna try to
fire me you're gonna pull Tony Khan over
the side and get me fired well how about
you do that Kody how about you fire me
oh wait that's right you won't because
the one thing you want most in this
world Kody is to get your hands on me
isn't it and to top that off you'd be
letting down each and every single one
of these people who you claim to care
about because what they want more than
anything is to see us go at it so you
people wanna see MJ yep first is Cody
Rhodes huh new people wanna see it
let me hear it
looked at for tody your eye
but but but but but but but but
[Applause]
Cody I got a couple of stipulations here
bud and I'll tell you those stipulations
but I'm not going to tell you those
stipulations here in Hong Ki bill USA
Texas
[Applause]
you guys got a problem with the truth
huh
[Applause]
now guys ow Cody
I'm gonna give you the stipulations in
Jacksonville oh and one more thing
before I leave Cody I want you to really
look on me cameraman really zoom in here
I know you're back there like a pitbull
on a leash foaming at the mouth just
praying a god
someone's gonna release you but here's
the thing bud and I want you to remember
this I'm in control now not you because
I'm better than you and you know it
[Music]
Wow stipulations coming in Jacksonville
that could be one of the more
interesting announces of the years